so there's a white nationalist uh
richard spencer who i've actually
interviewed on the program and i
encourage you to check that interview
out he's considered in some sense the
founder of the alt-right but he's
definitely
a white nationalist he said that that is
an appropriate term among others to be
using for him when i interviewed him on
the show a couple of years ago
and spencer has now been they're calling
it outed
but i don't actually know that that's
the right term he's been
quote outed by an audio tape where he
uses
all of the angry vitriolic slurs that
many white nationalists use about jews
and about black people now you might be
saying well
why is it notable that a white
nationalist was
using those terms about jews and black
people and the reason it's notable
is precisely because richard spencer's
entire
thing was yes he's a white nationalist
yes he wants a a a white ethno state
where everyone who is not as he calls it
of european
origin uh leaves the country but he's an
educated articulate elegant
well-dressed guy who wants those
things and he wants those things to
happen respectfully or something i mean
within the context of
how how respectfully can you have a an
ethnic cleansing right but the idea is
he doesn't scream at people
he doesn't use racial slurs he wants it
all to be peaceful and for everybody to
agree
that races are going to separate now all
along and this is why i say that the
term outed is maybe
a bit of an exaggeration anyone with any
common sense
probably guessed that behind closed
doors richard spencer was just your
normal average white supremacist
racist but he was able to kind of keep
up the facade for some time
he would couch his views in history or
sociology
or science as they claim now to be doing
in a very popular and sometimes
unfortunately effective way
but this is now all imploded so it just
so happens that the person who released
this audio tape
is another right-wing bomb thrower named
milo yiannopoulos who i actually emailed
with
about six or eight weeks ago didn't go
well that email exchange
the emails had nothing to do with this
milo has released the recording
it's bad we're going to listen to it now
nothing surprising about this
in some superficial sense this does
contain shocking
language so probably best as they say to
uh get the kids out of the room
we are coming back
i am so mad
humiliate them i am coming back here
every
weekend if i have to like this is never
over
i win
like me they look up and see a face like
mine looking down at them
that's how the world works we are going
to destroy this
town so of course you know talking about
[ __ ] and octoroons slurs for jews and
black people
so there's really only one takeaway here
actually i actually think that the
analysis here is a pretty simple one
richard spencer is just like all the
people that he claims to be different
from
right he says he's not some lowbrow
racist
he's not some abrasive uneducated yokel
or whatever right
because he's the dapper white
nationalist well this sounds just like
anybody else that you would imagine
white nationalists would be in cahoots
with he plays the polite well-dressed
white nationalist
who uses coded but arguably less
threatening sounding terms like
peaceful ethnic cleansing a kindler
gentler sort of white nationalism but
it's all the same stuff now why did milo
yiannopoulos publish this
he says quote as for why i published it
i have always publicly hated spencer
and he has always publicly hated me he
thinks i'm a degenerate race mixing [ __ ]
and i think he's a knuckle dragging
racist in a cheap suit
as you will recall he was paid to sneak
into a bar i was singing karaoke in
and throw up nazi salutes and film it
without my knowledge
so it has been very satisfying for me to
draw a crisp bright red line
between the two of us so there it is
it's just different
factions of the vile right in this case
they are clashing with each other
milo and richard spencer but the lesson
is
you've got to pay attention to the
substance and not the tone
because if you go back to the interview
that i did with spencer i believe it was
back in 2017
or you look at anything that he's done
if you listened
only to the substance of spencer for the
last however many years
this would not be even remotely
surprising to you you might still be
taken aback by the crass nature of the
language sure
but the substance would not be even
remotely surprising
the people who were surprised by this
had sort of been lulled by the tone
and the optics of richard spencer and
they weren't paying attention to the
substance that was a bad decision all
along
and this is just confirmation of that
nothing new nothing unusual nothing we
haven't heard before
just surprising some people because they
understood richard spencer to be more of
a
quote academic educated white
nationalist nothing new here and we'll
see if anything develops
as far as the release of the actual tape
and milo yiannopoulos's involvement
although it may be
you know another one of milo's attempts
to reinsert himself
into the political dialogue uh at least
within some enclaves of the internet
after he was
essentially completely pushed out after
comments about
i'm trying to remember is it technically
pedophilia or was it hebrewphilia now i
don't remember in any case
comments that were poorly they were not
well received even
by uh many of the factions of the right
that had previously embraced
milo